Hello world,
it's Saroj.
And our task today is to
build a recurrent network,
a type of recurrent network called an
Lstm or long short term memory network to
generate m and m lyrics,
that star task.
And we're going to build this without
using any libraries, just num Pi,
which is for Matrix math because we
want to learn about the math behind LSTM
networks.
We've talked about recurrent networks
earlier on in the series and the LSTs are
the next logical step in that
progression of neural network learnings.
So that's where we're going to do today.
And um,
we're gonna first talk
about recurrent networks.
We're going to do a little refresher
on what recurrent networks are,
how we can improve them,
and then we'll talk about LSTM networks
and how they are improvements and the
mathematics behind them.
Then we'll build all of this build as a,
we're going to look,
we're going to,
I'm going to explain the
code cause there's quite a
lot of code to go over here.
There's a lot of code.
Um,
but we're going to look at all the code
and then I'm going to code out manually
the forward propagation parts for both
the greater recurrent network and then
the LSTM cell itself.
So strap on with every math hat you have
because this is going to be so hard.
We might as well just give up. Let's just
forget this. No, no, I'm just kidding. No,
this is actually going to be,
there's going to be pretty easy.
This is going to be pretty easy.
If you got the recurring that video,
this is going to be pretty easy stuff,
although it's a little more complicated,
but you will get this. Okay.
Get, get ready for this.
I'm going to make sure you get
this. Okay. So here, here we go.
What is recurrent network?
Can you tell me what a recurrent
network is in one sentence?
I'll give you 10 seconds.
Go.
Okay.
That's all the time you get.
I'm not gonna wait a full 10 seconds
for current networks are cool.
They're useful for learning sequential
data. We know this, we know this.
data as series of video frames text.
Um, music, anything that
is a sequence of data,
that's where recurrent networks do really
well. That's what they're made for.
They're very simple. You have
your input, your input data,
and then you have your hidden state
and then you haven't helped put.
And so the different between recurrent
nets and feed forward nets are that
recurrent nets have
something different here.
So in a normal feed forward and
that we would have our input,
our hidden layer and then our
output layer and that's it.
And then we would have to wait matrices
between each of these layers that are
the, those are matrices,
right? That we multiply right?
Input Times weight at a bias activate.
Hopefully you said activate because
that is a rap slash mnemonic device.
But input times wait at a bias activate
repeat over and over for feedforward
networks.
A difference though for recurrent networks
is that we add another weight matrix
and this other weight matrix called
synapse h in this diagram connects the
hidden state back to itself.
So it's just a third weight matrix.
And what is the reason we
add that is so whenever we,
whenever we are training our network,
we're not just feeding in new data points.
So if the data's,
so if we're trying to train our
current net to remember the next uh,
to learn to predict the next number in
a series and the series is one through
10, right? We want to predict the
10 we would say, okay, one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine, 10. We wouldn't
just give it the numbers.
We would also feed in the hidden
state, right? So we would say, okay,
so given a one, predict the two. Okay, now
given the one and to predict the three,
okay, give him the one, two
and three, predict the four.
And that's how we would
train every iteration.
But that's not all we would give it.
We wouldn't just give it the input data.
We would also give it the hidden state.
We would give it both.
And so that's why we have a recurrent
matrix that's connecting the hidden state
to itself because we are not just giving
it, giving it every new data point,
the ones and the twos and threes.
We're also giving it the hidden state,
which is basically a,
which is a matrix and we're multiplying
it by the hidden state and the new input
data we are,
we are feeding in the hidden state
and the input data at every time step.
And so that's why we have a hidden matrix.
And so you could think of this as own
rolled as just a series of feedforward
networks,
right?
Or we give it an an an input data
point and then we get a hidden states.
And then in the next time step, we don't
just give it this new data point x one,
but we also give it the, the hidden
state from the previous time step.
So we just continued to do that.
So that's,
that's one way of looking at our
current network as just a big chain of
feedforward networks. A chain, right?
A block chain. No, not blockchain.
Although I do want to talk about
blockchain, it's coming. Don't worry,
I'm coming for you.
Blockchain, but not yet.
We're still talking about recurrent
networks. Amazing stuff. Amazing stuff.
Blockchains coming though. Oh, I
don't want to give away too much.
I just did anyway. Ah, okay. Uh,
you guys can tell I'm very
excited about blockchain anyway.
So we give it the hidden state and the
input at every time step and we just keep
repeating that. And that is a recurrent
network. But there is a problem here.
The problem is that,
uh,
there are 99 of these problems and no, I'm
just kidding. The problem is that when,
when, whenever, oh, so here's the problem.
The problem is actually
really interesting.
It's called the vanishing
gradient problem. Okay.
So it's called the vanishing gradient
problem. So let's say you're, you're like,
what is this?
So let's say we are trying to predict
the next word and a sequence of texts,
which is actually what we are
trying to do right now. Duh.
But let's say that's
what we're trying to do.
And let's say we're trying to predict
the last word in this sentence.
The grass is green, right?
So all were given. So we know
that the word is you know,
green,
but let's say we're trying to predict it.
So all we're giving is given is the
grass is and we're trying to predict that
last word. Recurrent networks
can do this, right? They,
they can easily do this
because the distance between
what the word we're trying
to predict the distance between that data
point in the sequence and the previous
data points is it's pretty small.
You write the different,
the distance between grass,
which is the context we need.
And Green is pretty small.
The only difference is that
the word is, is between,
is between those two words.
And so that's easy to predict because um,
that's the only context that we need.
Let's say it had some tendencies
before that said, you know, the,
the law in his reign or the grass is,
let's say you already
said the grass is greener.
So it's already like the previous
sentence. So it already made that,
that distinct connection
between grass and green.
And you know those two things are related.
So of course it's very easy to do that
but it, but let's also say, and you,
but let's also say that we want to
predict the next word in this sentence.
So let's say we have a huge paragraph.
Let's not even a parent.
Let's say we have a 30 page essay
and the beginning of the essay,
it is a first person essay and it's about
a guy named John. Okay is French dude.
He's got a mustache,
unnecessary detail,
but a guy named John and it starts
off with I am French as it should be,
I am French and then there's 2000 plus
other words and we're trying to predict
the,
the last sentence,
the last word after 2000 words
and that is the word French.
I speak fluent what?
And now let's say between I am
French and I speak fluent French.
There's all these other languages like
and so this guy is Spanish and I heard
some German on the subway and all of
that is actually irrelevant to what he
speaks fluently, which is French.
We've got to know that context.
We got to know that he is French. So of
course he's gonna speak fluent French.
So we've got to find a way for our
network to be able to remember longterm
dependencies. And so the whole
idea behind recurrent networks,
the whole reason that we feed in the
hidden state from the previous time step
for every new iteration it so that we
can have a form of neural memory, right?
That's why we don't just feed into the,
the previous input,
but we feed it in the previous hidden
state because the hidden state is that
matrix that represents the learnings,
the learnings of the network so that we
can give it a form of memory like what
is remember before and the
new data points. But the
problem and you would think,
okay, so that's all you need, right?
Of course the hidden state is
going to be updated more and more.
And the whole idea of recurrence is made
so that we have a form of neural memory
for sequences specifically.
But the problem is that when we're,
whenever we are back propagating,
the gradient tends to vantage.
So it's called the vanishing gradient
problem. So, let me explain this.
So whenever we're forward propagating,
we have our input data, right?
And we are trying to predict the next a
word or character or a musical note in
the sequence. And to what we do is we say
input times wait out of bias, activate,
repeat over and over. And then you know,
recurring over and over and over again.
And you get the output,
which is the prediction.
The prediction is the
next word or whatever.
And so once you had that prediction
value, then you're going to say, okay,
the doctor rise a prediction into a number
and say prediction minus the expected,
the, the, the expected output,
which is the actual label
or next word or character.
Cause we know it and
because it's a supervised.
And so then we have the
error value or lost value.
And then we use that air value to compute
the partial derivative with respect to
our weights going backwards in
our network. Recursively work,
performing gradient descent or in
the context of neural networks.
Backpropagation because we are back
propagating on error gradient across every
layer.
But what happens is that as the gradient,
remember this is a chain of operations.
The chain rule I would
happens is as we are, uh,
as we are propagating this gradient
value backwards across every layer we're
competing the partial derivative
with respect to the air bar,
the partial derivative of the
error with respect to our weights.
As we are doing that for
every layer recursively the
gradient value gets smaller
and smaller and smaller for the reason,
for linear algebraic reasons,
the gradient,
the gradient just gets smaller
and smaller and smaller.
And so what this means is
that the magnitude of the,
so the whole point of that propagation
of grading dissent is to improve our
weight values such that are expected
output is closer to such that our actually
sets that our predicted output. It's
closer to our expected output, right?
We were trying to
minimize the error value.
And so the whole point of gradient
descent is to give our weight values a
direction in which to update such that
the error is going to be minimized
through a forward pass.
And so by direction,
I'm talking about what,
what values in this weight matrix,
this set of numbers is optimal such
that if we were to multiply this by the
input and then you know,
do that over and over again,
it's going to give us the
rights, output value. And so
that's the whole reason we're computing
partial derivatives or gradients,
which we also call them because
calculus is a study of change, right?
Change whether it be in moving
bodies or change in terms of uh,
how to update a set of values.
And when I say direction,
it doesn't mean like a literal
direction, like up, down, left, right?
It means a direction in that,
um,
the numbers are closer to the ideal
optimal numbers that they should be in the
weight matrix.
So when we multiply the input by them,
the output is going to be closer
to the actual output that we want.
I probably repeated that several times,
but you know, it's good. It's good,
it's good for us. And so, so that's,
that's the whole point of a performing
gradient descent, Aka backpropagation.
And so the grading gets smaller.
And so what this means is that
the magnitude of change in the,
the first layers of the network is going
to be smaller than the magnitude of
change in the tail end of the
network. The last layers, right?
So the last layers are going to be,
um, more affected by the change,
but the,
the first layers are going to be not as
effective because the grading update is
smaller because, because the
grade itself is smaller and so,
okay.
Right? And there are two factors that
affect the magnitude of these gradients,
the weights and the activation functions.
And um,
each of these factors is smarter than one.
The gradients may vanish in time if larger
than one, an exploding might happen.
So that's called the exploding gradient
problem. The grade itself is too big,
so it can go either direction. Usually
it's vanishing gradient, but uh, yeah,
this is a problem,
right?
We want to somehow maintain that gradient
value as we are back propagating.
We want to maintain that error gradient
value so that it is at the full
magnitude that it should be to update
our weight values for every layer
recursively. In the correct way. We
want to maintain that rating value.
We want to remember that creating
value as we'd back propagate.
And so how do we remember a
gradient value? How do we remember,
remember is uh, a word, you know,
maintain, remember, you know,
whatever you want to call it.
And so the solution for this is called
using an LSTM cell or a long short term
memory cells.
And if you think about it,
the knowledge of our recurrent
network is pretty chaotic.
Like let's say we're trying to, you
know, a caption, uh, of a video,
a set of frames, a video, right? And it's,
he's a guy and he's eating a burger and
did the statue of Liberty is behind him.
So then there were the network things.
Okay, he must be in the United States,
but then he's eating Sushi and it thinks,
oh,
he must be in Japan just
cause it seemed Sushi,
but it forgot that he was just
behind the Statue of Liberty.
There exists Sushi Sushi places in New
York City too, right? And then, you know,
he's riding a boat and he thinks,
oh, he must be in, you know,
the odyssey or something,
but he's still in New York.
So we need the information to update less
chaotically to account for all of the
learnings, the memories that it's
learned over a vast period of time,
a vast sequence to be more accurate.
And so the solution for this
is called the LSTM cell,
and it replaces the RNN cell.
And so the RNN cell is input times
weight out of bias activates,
right? And would that be a weight
matrix that is connecting to itself?
And so the difference is an Lstm cell,
basically just you just
replace it with an Lstm cell.
You just take that out and you replace
it with an Lstm cell. And what it is,
it's is a more complicated or more
extensive series of matrix operations.
So let me, let me talk about what this
is. Okay, let me, let me give this a go.
So LSTM cells consist of three gates.
You've got an input gates right here.
You have your output gate right here.
You ever forget gate right here.
And then you have a cell state.
Now you also see this
input modulation gates.
So that's actually only use sometimes,
but uh, let's just forget about that.
That's,
that's just forget that exist.
You have an input gates on Kate's and
a forget gates. And so there's many,
there are many variants of Lstm is and
why you see this input modulation gates.
But the most used ones are just
input, output, forget, and cell state.
So just forget about the input
modulation gate for now. Okay,
so we've got three gate values
and then we have a cell state.
So you might be thinking, okay, so
what are these gates like? Like what,
what is a gate?
And so a gate is just like a layer.
A gate is a series of matrix operations
and it is input times weights out of
bias activate.
So in a way you could think of an
LSTM cell as kind of like a May neural
network.
These gates all have weights themselves.
So they all have their own
set of weight matrices.
That means that an Lstm cell
is fully differentiable.
That means that we can compute the
derivative of each of these components or
gates, uh, which means that we can
update them over time. We can learn,
we can have them learn over time.
And so,
uh, so these are the equations
for each of these, right?
So for forget gate or
implicated and applicate,
it's input times weight out
of bias activate where the
input it consists of the
input and the hidden state from
the previous time step. So,
and each of these weights, these gates
have their own set of white values.
And so what we want is we want a way
for our model to know what to forget and
what to remember and what to pay
attention to in what it's learned, right?
What is the relevant,
and that's called the attention mechanism.
What is the relevant data and everything
that it's learned. What is the,
um,
relevant part of what it's being fed
in this time step to remember and what
should forget the cell states is the
longterm memory it represents what all of
the learnings across all of time. The
hidden state is akin to working memory.
So it's kind of like a current memory.
The forget gate also called the re
remember vector learns what to forget and
what to remember, right? One
or zero binary outcome. This,
the input gate determines how much of
the input to let into the cell state also
called a save vector,
what to save and what not to.
And the output gate is akin
to an attention mechanism.
What part of that data should it focus on?
And so you might be thinking,
well how is like I see you
might be thinking like, okay,
so I see these equations,
I see how like input times wait antibodies
activate a t is akin to forgetting
and input and output. I see how there's
an ordering to this, right? We have,
we have an ordering to this. We first,
you know, go through an input. We,
we learned what we learned,
what to forget,
and then we compute that
cell state and then we,
and then we send it to the
output. Um, ultimate. But,
and then ultimately we compute
the cell and the hidden state.
And these are the two key
values that we output.
So you might see these and you might
think, okay, like I see the ordering,
I see how they represent for getting
and but I don't like make the connection
between still like how it knows
what to forget and what to remember.
And that's again,
that's the amazing thing about um,
neural networks like these, these gates
are essentially perceptrons there.
They're like mini networks,
right? With, with a single node.
The node is the gate itself,
right?
It's a single note what they
single activation function.
All of these gates are perceptrons,
they're like many neural networks,
like single layer neural networks. And it
learns what to forget, what to remember.
Um, based on gradient descent. Again,
it's the magic of grading dissent.
It learns what is necessary over time.
And so these,
these components represent mechanisms
for forgetting, remembering,
and what to pay attention to or attention.
And so that's what the and provides us.
So instead of,
so this equation would be for
a normal recurrent network.
So you would have your input times your
weight plus the hidden state times its
own hidden state to hidden state matrix.
You'd activate that.
And that would give you the hidden
state at the current time step.
The difference is that it would
look like this instead. It's a,
it's a more extensive
series of operations, right?
So that's what it is. And
uh, yeah. And so, yeah,
so that's kind of the high
level of how that works.
And now we're going to look
at it and code as well.
We're just going to help you know,
your retention.
But what are some use cases of this?
Like I said,
it's all sorts of sequential data,
any kind of texts,
any kind of sequence data,
it's going to,
it's going to be able to
learn what the next uh,
values in that sequence are,
which means it will be
able to both generate and
discriminate that type of data
that you've trained it on, right? In
this case, it's, it's, it's handled,
it's a characters that I can draw.
It can draw.
So this is very popular in NLP.
Andre Carpathy,
the famous AI researcher.
He has a great blog post on this,
the unreasonable effectiveness
of recurrent networks. I
assume you've read that.
If not, check it out. Um, I'll
also link to it, probably,
I'll link to it in the description.
And so yet to use for translation and
send them an analysis and all sorts of NLP
tasks. Uh, it's also used
for image classification.
Like if you think of a picture as a
sequence where each pixel is a sequence,
predict the next sequence.
So there's a lot of different
ways that we can frame our, our,
our problem and you know,
Ellis teams can be applied to
almost any problem. Very useful.
And so what are some other great
examples where I've got two.
One is for automatic speech
recognition with tensorflow. So yes,
it's a little abstracted with tensorflow,
but it's a really cool use case and
definitely something that checkout.
So check out that demo.
And then also, um, this,
this repository,
which is
just a visualization of Lstm,
which is going to definitely help with
your understanding to check out this
visualization. Very cool. Very cool demo.
Uh, it's in Javascript, I think. Yeah,
it's in javascript. Oh No, it's in
great. So yeah, so there's that.
Definitely check that out.
And so our steps are going to be the
look at the recurrent. Now we're class.
So we'll have a recurrent network class,
Plano Rucker and network.
And we're going to use
an LSTM cell instead.
So we're going to replace it and then
we'll build that LSTM class and then our
data loading functions for our text.
And then we'll train our model. Okay,
so what is this right here? This
jumble of numbers with no explanation.
This represents the forward pass,
the series of Matrix operations that
were computing, uh, to get our output,
our predicted output. Okay, so, and
we'll look at this and code. So,
okay, so a recurrent neural
network is going to remember.
So what we're going to do
is given our m and m text,
we're going to predict the input,
the next word in the sequence,
given the previous words.
So what that means is the input is going
to be all of those words that we have,
just every word and our output will be
the same thing, but just moved over one.
That means that, you know, it'll,
it'll look like this. Like, you know,
during training we have a series of,
you know, training iterations, right?
So we'll say, you know, like,
uh, let's say, you know,
my name is slim shady would be like
the, the text. So we would say my,
and we would try to predict
name, okay, we've got that, uh,
compute the error back propagate,
next iteration weights are updated,
my name and then we're going to try to
predict is right. And so then we say,
uh, try to predict is we
have an actual output.
We have a predicted output, compute
the error back propagate, repeat.
My name is, I'm trying to predict
slim. You see what I'm saying?
So we just keep doing that.
And so that's why it's moved over by one.
So our inputs and our outputs
are going to be our words.
We have the number of
recurrences that we want to do,
which is the number of words total,
right? Cause we're gonna, we're gonna,
we're going to perform recurrence in our
network for as many times as necessary
until we iterate through all those words
up until we get to that predicted ward
that we need to be at. And then we
have an array of expected outputs. Uh,
and then we have our learning rate,
which is our tuning up for, you know,
too low and it's never going to
converge to high and it'll convert it,
it'll overshoot, uh, and so we
will never converge as well.
So that's where our learning rate is.
So now let's look at this.
So we're going to do a
bunch of an initialization.
So remember the difference between LSTs
and Plano recurrent nets, or is our,
that we have more parameters, those,
those gate values, and we, uh,
have new operations for
those parameter values.
So we're going to initialize all of
those right at the beginning. And Look,
you might look at this and think, wow,
this is very complicated and difficult.
But remember with tensorflow,
with care os you can,
you can do this in 10 lines of
code 20, 30, 40 lines of code.
We're looking at the, at the details
here. That's why it looks so long. Okay.
So that's why it looks so long.
So now let's look at this.
So we're going to initialize our first
word, the size of it there, next word,
the size of that.
And then our weight matrix.
This is the weight matrix between
the input and the hidden state,
which we're going to initialize randomly
of this size of our predicted output.
Yeah.
Well, initialize this variable, gee,
that's going to be used for r m s prop,
which is a, a technique for gradient
descent that decays the learning rates.
I'll talk about why we're using g later
on. We're not ready for that right now,
but then we're going to compete,
we're going to say,
and then you tried the length
of the recurrent network, right?
That's the number of words that we have.
The number of recurrences are learning
rates. These are all parameters.
And now we're going to have a raise for
storing our inputs at every time step on
array for storing our cell states on a
ready for storing hormone output values
are hidden states. And then
our, um, take values, right,
are for gate values. Well, one
of them is actually a cell state.
These aren't LSTM values. So before
that, these were the, uh, network,
the recurrent network values,
and now he's the LSTM cell values.
And then we have our, our
array of expected output
values. And finally we have R,
l s t m cell, which we initialize right
here, giving it our inputs, our outputs,
the amount of occurrence
and the learning rate,
just like we did for the
recurring network. Remember,
it's like a mini network.
It's like a network in a network.
And if you think of the gates as networks,
and it's a network in a network
inside of a network or no,
it's three networks inside of a
network. Inside of a network. Okay.
So yeah, talk about inception, inception,
recurrence, inception.
So back to this. Um,
those are our initializations
and now we have our sigmoid,
which is our activation function.
It's a simple nonlinearity, right?
And then we have our derivative
of the sigmoid function,
which is used to compute gradients.
That's why we have the derivative. Right.
We'll talk about that in backpropagation.
And then we have four propagation,
which is our series of Matrix operations,
which I'm going to code. Okay. So for,
for propagation,
yeah,
we're going to do this in a loop,
right?
Because it's a recurrent network for
the number of, uh, loops that we want.
Right? Um, so we're going to say, okay,
so for the number of loops that we want,
that we define in our L,
we're going to set the
input for the LSTM cell,
that input for the LSTM cell,
which is a combination of inputs.
So we'll set,
which we can do with the h stack
function of num Pi, and we'll say,
okay,
hi.
Minus one or minus one.
And then self dot x
Lstm dot x equals NP softer.
And so this is the s, so this is how
we set inputs for the LTM sell by.
It's a combination of inputs from the
previous output and the previous hidden
states right here,
right? So that's, that's,
that's US initializing our LSTM cell,
and now we can run for propagation
through the LSTM cell itself.
So it's gonna Return. Our cell
states are hidden, states are,
forget gate are. So we can, you know,
store it in our array of values,
um,
c which is a cell state,
and then the output. And so we can
compute that using the forward prop,
a function of the LSTM cell.
And so then we're going to,
uh,
say,
let's
store the computed cell state,
right?
So then we've got all these values
and now we can store them locally,
uh, uh, in this, in this
recurrent networks memory,
these are all values that were computed
from the forward propagation of the LSTM
cell.
And so we can just, you know,
set the, the hidden state.
We've got our, uh, what else do we
have? We have our, uh, forget gates.
Of course the forget gate is
going to be a set as well.
These are all values that we computed
in our Ford propagation states.
We have our input gates,
uh,
which we're going to set like that.
We have our cell state,
and then we have our output gate,
right? These are all
values. We competed there.
Now we can calculate the output by
multiplying the hidden state, uh,
with the weight matrix. So input
times wait, alibis activate.
So we'll say,
okay,
we'll compute that output by saying
self dot sigmoids we'll use a sigmoid
function to activate the
wait times the input
input times we'd had a
bias activate, right? Yup.
And then we'll set our inputs
cause we've computed an output.
We want to set our input to the
next word in the sequence, right?
Cause we're gonna,
we're gonna keep going.
Okay.
And then when we're done with that,
we can return
the output prediction.
Okay.
Right? So that's forward propagation.
That's forward propagation.
Now for backward propagation,
we're going to, um, look at this.
So we're going to update our weight
matrices. Uh, that's, that's what,
that's the point of backpropagation
to update our weight matrices with our
learnings.
So we've computed at predicted next
word and we have our actual next word.
And we represent these words as numbers,
as vectors,
so that we can compute the
difference between words.
Like how do you compute the
difference between words?
Well you convert them
to numbers or vectors,
then we can compute the
difference to get the air value.
So we'll initialize the error is zero.
And then we'll um,
initialize to a empty res,
um, to empty vectors for the
cell state and the hidden state.
Remember the cell state in the hidden
state where those two values right here,
which ultimately these forget input
output gates are used to help compute the
value of right. Notice how, forget
input and output are used here.
That the forget gate is multiplied
by the working memory state. Um,
and then we add the input gate which and
multiplied by the working memory state
as well, uh, to remember what to forget,
to learn,
what to forget and what to remember.
And that's what's stored in our cells
state the learnings of the forget and the
input gates.
And we then we then activates the cell
state and multiply it by the output to
get our hidden state.
And so we have for our level,
with a weight matrix between the
input and the hidden the states,
we have our hidden state
itself and in the cell state.
And those are the key like
outer level, um, uh, parameters.
And then our inner level parameters are
those LSTM level gradients, right? So,
so we want the creating
values for our forget gate,
our input gate or sell ourselves unit
or state, and then our output gate,
the internal ones. And so we're
going to fill these out. So, uh,
we're gonna loop backwards our backdrop,
the gate through time,
through our recurrence. So we're gonna
say we have our calculator output,
let's compute the air between
that and the expected output.
And then we're going to say,
okay,
we're going to compute the
partial derivative vice computing,
the error times a derivative of
the output times the hidden state.
And so once we have that,
then we can say, okay,
it's time to propagate
the air back to the,
to the exit of the Lstm cell or
the, the, the, the way out to,
to the outputs of their recurrent network
in general. So the way we do that, it's,
it's three steps.
We do,
we compute the error times the
recurrent network weight matrix,
and then we set the input values
of the LSTM cell for recurrence.
We set the input values of
the LSTM cell for recurrence.
And then finally we set the cell state
of the LSTM cell for recurrence pre like
that's pre updates and then
we recursively called this backpropagation
using these newly computed values.
Right? So for our, for uh,
this is going to compute gradient updates
for our forget input cell unit and
help locates and the s they'll have the
higher level cell state and the hidden
state. Those two higher
level, uh, parameters.
And so these are all of our gradients.
And now we can,
this is just for air logging.
Now we can accumulate those gradient
updates by adding them to our existing
empty valleys that we
initialize right at the start.
And then we can update our LSTM major
cs with the average of the accumulated
gradient updates and then update our
weight matrix with the average of the
accumulated grade updates and return
the total error of this iteration.
And that's backpropagation in general.
So then,
okay,
uh,
so then,
okay,
so notice this update step
with this update step is,
is rms prop. It's a way of,
the cane are, uh,
learning rates over time.
And this improves convergence.
There's a lot of different methodologies
for improving on gradient descent.
There's Adam, there's rms
prop, there's, um, at a Grad,
there's a bunch of these
in rms properties, one of
them. But here's the formula.
I'll just put it up there.
Okay? So that's what this is.
Okay.
So now we will.
And so the sample function is the same
thing as a forward propagation function.
It's just,
it's,
it's what we're gonna use
once we've trained our model
to predict or to generate
new words. So it's the same thing, right?
We have our input and for
a number of words that we
defined, we'll say, you know,
generate words or predict words for
as many iterations as we defined.
So it's the same thing. So we can
just skip that. Now for our LSTM cell.
So for our LSTM cell,
we've given it the same parameters
as we did for our recurrent network.
It is after all a mini network in and
of itself. So it gave it the inputs,
the outputs, the amount of
recurrence and the learning rate.
And so what we'll do is very similar
at the start to what we did for our
recurrent network will in
it will initialize, um,
our input the size of it or help put the
size of it and then our cell state is
going to be empty.
How often should we perform a current,
we'll initialize that variable
are learning rate as well.
And now we're going to
create weight matrices.
We'll initialize these weight matrix.
He's randomly just like we would for a,
any kind of neural network will neutralize
of weight matrices for our three gate
values for our,
forget our implicates and our
application as well as our cell state.
So the cell state itself,
let me go up here,
has uh, uh, uh, set of
weight, major CS, right?
Just like all recurrent net,
all neural networks.
And so that node has its own
set of weight. Major sees that,
that we multiply to get
that output value right?
It's a part of a series of operations.
And the weight matrix is that
learning part. It's the non static,
it's the dynamic part of that equation
that would essentially you can think of
these as gates. You can think of them as
layers even. Um, but they're called gates,
but layers are very similar.
You know what I'm saying?
The layers are very similar.
Input Times weight added bias activate,
but we called them gates to differentiate,
not to be confused with so
many terms here, not to,
not to be confused with the actual
mathematical term differentiate but to
discriminate. Right. Okay. So back to
this. So now, um, we're, we're, we,
we initialized our gates,
we and then we've initialize our gates
and now empty bellies for gradients that
we're going to compute for all of these.
Remember all of these
gates are differentiable.
So that's where these grading values,
we'll go sit down,
we can update them through backpropagation
because we back propagate through,
that's the cell itself.
We don't just back propagate through
the recurrent network at a high level.
We are back propagating.
That is we are competing gray and
values for each of these gates.
So we were updating waits for
the input for get a cell state,
the outputs, Gates where, and the, uh,
outer level weight matrix as
well for the recurring network.
So we're competing gradings for
everything. So we're updating everything.
It's learning what to forget, what to
remember, what to pay attention to,
the attention mechanism,
the output, and um,
okay.
The outer level weight
Matrix as well. So, right.
So then we have our activation functions
sigmoid just like before and our
derivative just like before.
And so what we do is we add
another activation function here.
This is good practice in LSTM networks.
You usually see the Tan h function applied
pretty much all the time. And did the,
you might be asking, well, why do we use
10 age over other activation functions?
I've got a great video
on this. It's called, um,
which activation function
should I use search,
which activation function should I
use? CREPE video on this? And you'll,
you'll know it very fast within seven
minutes if you watch that video.
But I'm at a high level, it prevents
the vanishing gradient problem.
The Tan h function gives
us stronger gradients. Uh,
since the data is centered around zero,
as opposed to the sigmoid, which is not.
Um, and so we use that.
And then we also, uh,
are going to import the derivative
function of it because we went to compute
gradients, right? Everything is
differentiable. So just like before,
will compute the for
propagation for an LSTM cell.
And so remember the four propagation
for an Lstm cell is drum roll please.
This set of operations, ultimately, uh,
we want to compute the output,
right? We want to compute the output.
So that's what we'll do
back to this.
So we'll say
the forget gate is going to equal
the input times that forgetting.
So we're going to activate the
dot product of the forget decades and
the input input times for get paid and
then activate.
That's going to give us our forget gates.
And then we're going to compute this,
the cell state. We're gonna, we're gonna,
we're gonna update the cell state by
multiplying it by that for decades.
So it knows what to forget.
And then we're going to compute the input,
which is going to be again,
the activated version of
d,
uh,
input times the previous input,
the current input times or previous input.
And so that's going to tell us that.
And so then
once we've got that,
we can
compute the cell state,
which we're going to apply this new
activation function for the cell states to
prevent the vantage and gradient,
which is the cell stayed Timesi input.
And then we activate bride,
that series of operations.
And then we're going to
update the cell state
by adding the input to times the cell,
state the cell and put times a cell.
And then for a predicted output,
we're going to take those.
We're going to say let's compete the
dot product between the output gates and
the cell state or no,
the applicate and the input
that's going to go to our
predicted output. And so
what we can do is we can say,
oh no, that's going to give us apart how
put gate and to get our actual output,
our predicted output,
we'll we'll multiply our output gate
times the activated version of our self
state and that's going to
give us our predicted output.
We can then return our cell
states are predicted output,
forget gates in implicate cell,
and then our output gates as well.
That's for propagation. All
right, and that's the equation
that I showed up there.
So now we've got our forward propagation.
Now we're going to look at
the backward propagation.
Remember we back propagate
through the self state as well,
not just the higher level
recurrent network. So what this is
okay
is we're going to compute
the the first error, right?
So that's the error plus the hidden
states derivative and we'll clip those
values so it's not too big. We want to
prevent the gradient from vanishing.
So clipping,
it helps that and we'll multiply the air
by the activated cell state to compute
the output derivative and then
will compute the output updates,
which is the output derivatives times
the activated output times the input.
And then we'll compete the
derivative of the cell state,
which is error times output,
time to draw it it.
Oh the cell state plus to derivative cell.
So we're computing derivatives of all of
these components in the backwards order
that's before,
which means that forget the forget gate
computation or update will happen near
the end instead of near the beginning.
And so then we're competing the driven
of the cell and then the cell update,
the derivative of the input, the
input update, the derivative of the,
forget the forget update.
So you see what I'm saying?
We're computing gradients and
then we're updating them, right?
And then derivative of the cell state and
then the driven off the hidden states.
And then finally we can, we can return
all of those great value, these,
those updated grading values for the,
forget the input, the cell, the output,
the self states and the hidden state.
So many different parameters that
we have computed gradings for and
backpropagation is going to let
us compute all of those. Right?
Recursively um,
computing the air with respect to our
weights for every single component we have
in that now work in the reverse order
that we did forward propagation.
And so,
okay.
Yeah. It's just, you know, it's, it's more
matrix math than we did before. It's like,
it's like six or seven more
steps than a recurrent network.
Maybe it's more like eight
or nine more steps, but yeah.
Okay.
And then our, our updates step is
going to just be us updating our,
forget input cell and Alpa gradients
and then we can update our gates using
those grading values and
there are grading values.
Okay.
So then that's it for our LSTM cell are
recurring network and now we can look at
our load text and our export text
function, which are not as interesting.
But what we do is we load up
our eminent text file of lyrics,
right?
Just like that.
And then we compute those
unique words for all of them.
And so we have a sequence,
right? We have a sequence,
our input and output sequence,
and then we have this export texts.
So whenever we've sampled new words,
we can write them from memory to disc.
That's all. And so for our
program we'll say, okay,
if so for 5,000 iterations with the
learning rate of 0.01 let's load the input
and our output data and then we'll
initialize a recurrent network using our
hyper parameters that
we've initialized before.
And then for training time for
that given number of iterations,
5,000 we'll say compute
the predicted next words.
So that's the forward propagation.
Then perform backpropagation to
update all our weight values,
use you aren't error.
And then if our air and then just
keep doing them and then this,
this catch or this,
this estate.
And we'll say if our error is small
enough that it's between this range here,
then we can go ahead and sample,
which means predict new words,
generate new words or network
is trained our errors, smallest.
Let's go ahead and now just predict
new words without having to compute
backpropagation to update our weights
are weights are already updated enough.
So then we can go ahead and define a
seed word and then predict some new texts
by calling that sample function, which
is the four propagation. That's all.
And then we can write it all to disk.
Okay.
Right.
So let's run this.
Okay.
It's beginning.
It's going to take a while.
Yeah.
And then once it's done,
I actually have a saved copy.
It's spitting out some pretty dope lyrics,
right?
These are some pretty dope lyrics,
right? That's it for this lesson.
Definitely look at this
Jupiter notebook afterwards.
A look at those links that I have sent
you in the description as well as inside
of the Jupiter Notebook and make
sure that you understand, um,
why,
how at least why to use LSTM cells.
The reason is because it's to
remember longterm dependencies.
That's at least a high level and you
should've got from this video and learns
what to forget, what to remember
and what to pay attention to.
Those are the three things at an LSTM
cell as opposed to a regular recurring
network lets you do. Okay. So yeah,
please subscribe for more
programming videos. And for now,
I've got to learn to forget.
So thanks for watching.